madame rené clément et oui c'est la
quatrième de l'émission qui habitait là
antibruit des âmes purgatoire un joli
nom nous écrit le 12 mars dernièrement
un nom bientôt comme le temps passe
n'est ce pas jacqueline mais aussi comme
vous pouvez le constater avec nous deux
il faut garder l'espoir ce n'est pas
parce que vous n'obtenez pas une réponse
immédiate qu'il faut vous tracasser bref
madame clément avait des problèmes de
copropriété elle n'entre pas dans les
détails ou plus exactement c'est la
seule chose dont elle nous paraît ce
propos les termes employés dans la
lettre qu'elle a reçues ratifié entériné
quorum quitus délégation pouvoir
déontologie rétorsion coercition avec
cela écrit-elle gérard pas bio c'est moi
bonjour madame ne pourrait-il faire un
micro trottoir au que si madame clément
le voit signifie ratifié madame
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle un train de
vie oui c'est un train ou c'est pas un
wagon de marchandises qui a pas de
légumes qu'on peut s'installer
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle le quitus
monsieur un produit qui tue les insectes
qu'est ce que ça signifie la déontologie
à votre avis ça signifie que la vente
que je sais pas on peut pas recevoir du
monde sur la parole en disant qu'au
niveau où ça au logis à la maison
monsieur l'expression vous connaissiez
vous aviez entendu déjà mesures de
rétorsion et j'avais entendu oui mon
beau frère qu'il y en ait qui nous
faisait ça votre beau-frère parler de
mesures de rétorsion et pourquoi votre
beau-frère parlait-il de mesures de
rétorsion alors le vêtement on tombe
bien quand on dit le quorum par exemple
de quoi s'agit-il
ça a été le coup ce mélange de des roms
avec c'est pas eu qu'une certaine qui ne
sait pas à quoi avec certaines liquides
lesquels
il exhibe match et de l'autre d'un fort
affaiblissement je peux faire leurs
obsèques d'avoir comme celle pour le
quorum non pour leurs hommes ou leurs
hommes pas pour le quorum non pour
l'europe alors le quorum on m'avait dit
c'est quoi ces eaux ni mis de l'eau au
mélange une certaine liquide dans le
quorum moi je peux faire les roms q'elle
quorum quelques roms à votre avis un
embargo qu'est ce que c'est jetons
bâteaux un bâteau comment un bateau qui
peut arriver jusqu'ici la voiture c'est
tout c'est un petit bateau dont petit
bateau mais qui porte beaucoup de monde
sur ce bateau un embargo
ben je pense que c'est la sciatique ce
qu'on appelle la sciatique et c'est
descendent toute la longueur des reins
et sablé rejoint tous appellent ça le
terme servir tel entériné qu'est ce que
c'est mais entériné et quand on entérine
du foie gras ou du pâté de lierre ou de
la paix et tout est ce que vous avez
déjà entériné ou même le foie gras est
un gestionnaire qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un gestionnaire et pourquoi un
agent de police
j'ai juste eu à nos homologues qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une personne qui pense
tout seul dans quels domaines alors
pourquoi qui fait du théâtre du théâtre
ou alors malade mental je sais pas quoi
qu'appelle-t-on l'analogie c'est un
terme médical qui correspond à un tous
les maux dans le bas du dos comme les
hémorroïdes et
et tout ce qui concerne pourquoi
analogie alors parce que ça concerne ça
vienne du bois nu ce qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une mise en demeure qui sont sur le
trottoir qu'on aimait à l'intérieur quoi
à l'intérieur des maisons et jardins bio
et son analogie toujours la finesse
usher les rats en un peu ontologie nous
quand il revient aux reportages ces
sujets dans l'émail et pousse à la
timbale maintenant